♪ (intro music) ♪
With Flutter, making a scrollable grid
of widgets is easy with GridView.
But what about
if you have a grid of widgets
that you don't want to scroll?
That's what Table is for!
Especially if you have widgets
of different sizes,
there's no need to build up your own tree
of custom-size rows and columns.
Table can resize children,
which is to accommodate
all of its contents.
You can specify how widgets
are aligned vertically
and their relative widths
of columns horizontally.
You can set this specific behavior
for individual columns
with the columnWidths parameter.
Use the border parameter to add
a border decoration around your table.
For more info on Table
and all the other Flutter widgets,
check out flutter.io
♪ (music) ♪